good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson's night little news alert for
you nancy pelosi is even more agitated
tonight than usual on a conference call
just hours ago pelosi demanded that her
members vote immediately on a piece of
legislation she says is critical to our
national security
the bill she's talking about among other
things in affirms the central importance
of national borders well of course it
does without a border you can't have a
country and nancy pelosi firmly believes
that in fact she believes it so strongly
she's directing the biden administration
to develop an urgent new plan to keep
the border secure in fact not simply
secure
but in the words of the new legislation
section 208 invaluable meaning
impossible to breach walled up and
buttoned down bulletproof that's quite a
border
but why wouldn't it be when it comes to
borders nancy pelosi isn't messing
around are you surprised to hear this
well you may have misunderstood pelosi
isn't talking about the u.s border the
one that's currently open she's talking
about the ukrainian border the one that
actually matters
the bill pelosi is promoting is called
the defending ukraine sovereignty act
its purpose is to guarantee quote
ukraine sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity these are the
things that all countries need we'd love
to have them here
but no we're gonna have to wait ukraine
is ahead of us in the queue for secure
borders and honestly you can see why
as he used to say when we were kids
growing up in the united states what's
good for the lightly populated russian
colony of ukraine is good for us
as our oldest and most cherished ally
yoked tightly to the american people by
the ancient bonds of friendship shared
culture and burisma ukraine comes first
it has to come first
when caravans of undocumented russians
appear on the ukrainian border the
united states doesn't sit idly by the
united states swoops in with deadly
weapons to push these people back
we'll send missiles to ukraine if we
have to in fact we already have billions
of dollars worth
but wait a second you ask
isn't undocumented immigration a good
thing
doesn't immigration increase diversity
the blessed source of all beauty power
and strength well sure
most of the time it does
but not in ukraine
ukraine exists for the exclusive
presence of ukrainians
people who look or speak differently
people from other places would say
different religions are not allowed in
ukraine period that's nancy pelosi's
position ukraine is the one place nancy
pelosi very much wants to keep racially
pure she's willing to use lethal force
to do that virtually everyone in
congress agrees with pelosi so does the
white house here's joe biden's deputy
national security advisor explaining
that when undocumented foreign nationals
arrive in ukraine
they'll be killed
why should americans
care
about what's happening in ukraine
because it goes to a very fundamental
principle of of all nations which is
that our borders should be inviolate
that our sovereignty should be respected
our borders should be inviolate our
sovereignty should be respected meaning
ukraine's
that man was jonathan feiner he's
biden's deputy national security adviser
it's interesting to note that jonathan
feiner has no relevant experience for
the job he currently holds at one point
he was a washington post reporter that's
reassuring most recently he was cashing
into a private equity firm paying
approximately half the federal tax rate
you are good for him
but one thing jonathan feiner has
learned along the way
is that ukrainian borders matter if you
cross without position permission you
will be droned into the next life
kamala harris strongly agrees with that
here's harris threatening would-be
russian immigrants
the bottom line is that we have been
clear
and consistent for quite some time that
we respect the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of
ukraine and we expect that
russia would do the same and any
aggressive action taken by vladimir
putin will be met with severe
consequences
severe consequences
the understatement is chilly
that woman is bloodthirsty that's our
borders are try to cross the border and
we'll take out your entire caravan claim
asylum what's asylum
don't think so one toe over the line and
you're dead
those are strong words but kamal harris
appears to mean them she probably does
mean them but again you should know that
kamala harris is not talking about our
border here in the u.s she's talking
about the ukrainian border now what's
the difference between the two well the
ukrainian border by contrast is a place
the pentagon is willing to defend watch
8 500 u.s military personnel on
heightened alert is this the ceiling of
military personnel that the
administration will be committing to
this conflict do you see
well it's what we're talking about today
is is about 8 500 on heightened alert
but as i said yesterday we're certainly
not going to rule out other options our
job is to provide options to the
president to the commander-in-chief
and we're going to continue to do that
and so i would you know i certainly
would not rule out the possibility that
we could be putting additional forces on
heightened alert in the coming days and
weeks
and maybe even moving troops around
europe that are already there uh to
bolster and to reassure some of our
allies on the ground in the on the
continent
wait we're only sending 8 500 american
troops to protect the ukrainian border
asked the teleprompter well says john
kirby actually we could send a lot more
they're all poised to secure the sacred
ukrainian border
so you may be wondering how does that
commitment compare to what the pentagon
is willing to deploy to our southern
border
well let's see a little back of the
envelope math here
it's exactly 8 500 more because there
are no troops no american troops heading
to our southern border
that may seem distressing to you but in
a way it makes sense ukraine needs the
troops ukraine hasn't been invaded yet
we have been invaded and we lost
we've been defeated
and like all vanquished nations were
being treated with humiliating contempt
by world leaders in this case by our own
leaders
customs and border protection just
released the latest statistics on the
invasion ongoing into this country in
the month of december last month the
feds encountered close to 180 000
illegal immigrants foreign nationals
whose identities we can't know on the
southwest border here all living here
now
how many people is that well for
perspective that's more than the three
previous decembers combined
in the last calendar year more than 2
million
foreign nationals swept across the
mexican border unimpeded into this
country and now live here
that's a lot of people many times the
population of boston atlanta denver pick
a city in one year
but you know what's more than
it's a lot more than the russian army
has masked on the ukrainian border
something we're all hysterical about
and of course it's not just people
coming illegal in legally into this
country it's the drugs they are bringing
record amounts of narcotics narcotics
that are driving the single most deadly
drug epidemic in the history of this
country
you probably know someone who's had a
loved one die
not just habitual drug users but people
using drugs recreationally they're mixed
with fentanyl and they're dead thousands
and thousands more than a hundred
thousand in one year
who's doing this the cartels
they're killing far more americans than
vladimir putin ever could and they're
doing it with the help of the bite
administration
but in the meantime we've got two
million more than new people living in
this country who are they well we can't
say for sure no one really knows who
they are that's part of the problem in
an age when the rest of us are followed
and surveilled and show your medical
papers here's some facial recognition
software we're letting in too many
people we can't prove who they are we
have no way of doing that don't let them
lie to you
we do know they're coming from all over
the world
fox's bill malugion has been virtually
the only person in american media to
keep track of what is happening here
here's part of what he found
video from a law enforcement source
shows a single massive group of about
400 migrants who crossed illegally into
eagle pass texas on wednesday night
border patrol photos show the size of
that group with the sector chief himself
saying this was no coincidence it was
orchestrated by criminal elements for
money the night before the exact same
thing happened photos from border patrol
show another group of 400 after they
crossed illegally into eagle pass
tuesday night
here in the rio grande valley we
embedded with texas dps as they tracked
down runners in the brush looking to
evade near la jolla texas two men in
this group were from china
that was bill malujian on the border
he's still there go back to in just a
moment but this is an ongoing assault on
our national sovereignty on our
territorial integrity the things we've
been hearing for the last month are so
vitally important in ukraine
how's this happen who's the vladimir
putin in this morality tale well that
would be joe biden
this has all been allowed enabled
encouraged by joe biden with the help of
big corporations and left-wing
non-profits
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas who really should be charged
with a crime but hasn't been yet
recently bragged to cbs news that we're
quoting we have fundamentally changed
immigration enforcement in the interior
and we're continuing the quote for the
first time ever our policy explicitly
states that a non-citizen's unlawful
presence in the united states will not
by itself be a basis for the initiation
of an enforcement action
so what does that mean exactly
so
this is the guy charged with enforcing
immigration laws laws that he did not
create he's in the executive branch they
don't create laws
but here's the guy in charge of
enforcing them bragging that he's
decided to ignore federal law these are
the laws that our congress was elected
to pass
oh
thwarting democracy anyone pay no
attention vladimir putin's the one who
threatens democracy
everything's fine in this country we're
doing what you elected us to do they're
not even trying
facebook's not a threat to democracy how
could it be mark zuckerberg funds the
democratic party he's a good guy
but facebook is encouraging this
invasion too
facebook helps its users share
information on how to cross the border
illegally and how to break our laws
do they encourage users to
cook meth
here's how you make fentanyl here's how
child trafficking can make you millions
those are crimes too
we can't say that they're doing that
they're encouraging the breaking of
federal immigration law we're not
guessing about this facebook admitted it
recently to the attorney general of the
state of arizona we're quoting we do
allow people to share information about
how to enter a country illegally or
request information about how to be
smuggled
about how to be smuggled facebook is
helping people who quote want to be
smuggled
in addition to being totally evil these
people have no self-awareness imagine
saying something like that uber does it
too uber drivers are picking up illegal
migrants from the border we know because
fox news spoke to one driver in arizona
who said quote
i just will get a notification of a
pickup head down to the location there
will be a group of 20 plus immigrants
standing on the corner waiting for ubers
so again
if facebook and uber
were abetting child trafficking which on
some level they are
because child trafficking is an integral
part of illegal immigration so it's drug
trafficking
maybe someone wake up and do something
about it
you're seeing people rotting in solitary
because they trespassed in the capital
but uber and facebook are helping people
violate federal law and we don't care
no one in congress is investigating any
of this
sounds like sedition to us
but they're busy they're sending
hundreds of millions of dollars of
lethal weapons to ukraine to help with
their border pentagon's not sending
troops to our border they're sending him
to ukraine's border so that's the bite
administration's approach that approach
is virtually uncontested in washington
here's mitch mcconnell who poses by day
as leader of the opposition in the
senate
what i've been hearing since then is
encouraging
that
they're prepared
to
take steps
before
an incursion not afterwards
i've not been near the news this morning
so i'm not sure what additionally
may have occurred
but it appears to me the
administration's moving in the right
direction
yeah it appears that way if the
direction you want to move is to
completely change the population of the
country for political reasons let two
million people in in one year people
whose identities you can't confirm whose
intentions you don't know who are
bringing with them records amounts of
narcotics that killed over 100 000
americans if that's the goal then mitch
mcconnell you're on to something you're
moving in the right direction but if the
goal is to have a first world country
where laws mean something probably not
the right direction so why are you
telling us otherwise mitch mcconnell who
are you working for exactly
whose side are you on i think we know
who's paying for all this stuff well you
are
american citizens are paying for it the
united nations which takes billions of
u.s tax dollars is paying for it too
they're giving out cash to illegal
migrants heading to our border an
investigation by the center for
immigration studies found the u.n has
been handing out cash debit cards to u.s
bound illegal aliens and giving them
advice on how to claim asylum in our
country on how to game our system and
how to make a mockery of our laws they
don't respect us we don't respect
ourselves enough to stop this
once these migrants get here our
authorities do everything possible to
make sure they stay the bite
administration attempted on day one to
pause all deportations that moratorium
thank god was blocked by a federal judge
but it hardly matters
the administration is continuing to abet
criminal behavior they're allowing
illegals to use their arrest warrants as
id in airports you try that sorry you
don't have my id but i do have my arrest
warrant can i get housing subsidies food
stamps free health care and a flight
sure you can you're from another country
americans don't get that here's another
report from bill malugen
tsa confirms to fox news that the agency
is allowing illegal immigrants to use
arrest warrants as id at security
checkpoints in airports telling us in
part quote for non-citizens and non-u.s
nationals who do not otherwise have
acceptable forms of id for presentation
at security checkpoints tsa may also
accept certain dhs issued forms
including ice form i-200 warrant for
arrest of an alien
you just can't repeat this enough and
again we're doing this not because we
think it's going to change anything it
won't
this is just a tv show but we want a
record of what's happening right now
history is rewritten
unfortunately by the victors
and the details disappear but we think
the details are important we think we
all should be allowed to know why this
is happening and how it's happening so
just to restate
we're allowing foreigners who came here
illegally in violation of our laws
which are unenforced by our current
government which is undermined
undermining democracy by its refusal to
enforce those laws those people get to
use their arrest warrants to get on
airplanes while you have to show id
meanwhile again you can't say this
enough we'll stop after this congress is
doing everything it can pulling out all
the stops to send more money to eastern
europe to protect the borders of ukraine
it's like it's not even real but it is
real hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else